you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Holly genic risk score analyst
for Alzheimer's disease risk presented
by dr. Richard pethor CEO of site ox I'm
Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit them
at thermo Fisher com now let's get
started I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. Richard tether CEO of sight
ox dr. Pitzer has been involved in the
development of diagnostic and
therapeutic pharmaceutical products for
more than 25 years he's been the CEO at
site ox for the past seven years a
precision medicine working on developing
and commercializing a new diagnostic
technology for assessing Alzheimer's
disease risk for complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr. pepper
you may now begin your presentation
welcome sir
thank you Susie and hello everyone it's
a pleasure to be able to talk to you
today about apologetic risk score
analysis or else on disease risk and the
opportunities that this affords
much-needed opportunities for
transforming the prospects for
development of new
our planetary pew ticks during the
course of my presentation I'm going to
be covering an introduction to the
clinical challenges of Alzheimer's
disease and associated drug development
I'm going to be talking about apologetic
risks goals and how they can be used and
specifically how they pertain to the
genetics of Alzheimer's disease and and
what we've been developing at site ox
which is apologetic risk score algorithm
with the trade name of genus core and
how that performs in longitudinal
clinical studies and the subsequent
implications for stratifying subjects
into clinical trials for the future and
the prospects for clinical trial
enrichment and of course that in turn
will influence very positively we think
the prospects the new drug development
you can see on this slide which
describes the challenges about sinus
disease the huge problem that we the
industry faces Alzheimer's disease is
the most common form of Deventer
dementia but it is one of four or five
recognized types constitutes between 50
up to 70% of dementia and the problem
that the world faces today is this
escalating problem associated with an
aging demographic in the developed world
the costs today are estimated at about
800 billion worldwide and they will
travel by 2050 and one of the challenges
associated with the development of new
drugs is addressing the the failure rate
we have not seen any significant new
drug approvals in 2003 and that's
associated with the problems of finding
the correct subjects for enrollment at
the earliest stages of the disease where
the drugs that were in development have
the best prospects for working to the
point where the screening failure rate
is over 90% in some studies we what I'm
going to talk about today is how
genetics and polygenic risk scores in
particular can help improve that success
rate so of course outside of disease is
not purely a genetic disease and I'm
talking about the late onset form of the
disease as I'll describe
the moment but actually manifests itself
as a consequence of genetic inheritance
and also exposure to environmental and
lifestyle risks and that's illustrated
on this slide here we're all all with an
inherited level of genetic risk the
question is whether that risk becomes
manifest at the level of disease
symptoms and as we can see as we get
older those symptoms can be very mild in
the preclinical or prodromal phase of
the disease and then manifest as clear
dementia later on whether or not a
defined genetic risk becomes manifest at
the level of symptoms seems to be a
measure of how well we manage our
exposure to other risk factors and I've
listed some of them on this slide such
as cardiovascular risk hypertension
whether we take regular exercise and eat
a sensible diet whether we have diabetes
or the diabetes is under control a whole
series of things that can be managed in
high genetic risk individual might well
push back at the time of which symptoms
become apparent and that's that's very
important in terms of clinical
management considerations going forward
now there are a number of ways we can
intervene to decide whether or not
someone is in the high-risk category
today by the use of very invasive and
very expensive biomarkers but these have
significant limitations so if we look at
the left hand side of the slide here we
can see a two curve the yellow curve
associated with normal age-related
memory loss as we all get older or
cognitive functions tend to decline
naturally the very slowly and what some
of us will be on land more precipitous
blue and red curve associated with
Alzheimer's disease and this is not a
normal aging process what is happening
at the time of those symptoms were
actually about twenty to thirty years
before those symptoms is a buildup of
underlying pathology in the brain
associated
with amyloid plaque neurofibroma tangles
and other pathologies and and so that we
have a wind that we have a 20 or 25 year
window where we could intervene that
artistically to actually affect the the
outcome of that disease process so on
the right hand side of this slide on
slide five we've Illustrated here a
couple of the techniques of the use
today in the form of amyloid positive
positron emission tomography imaging
which is effective at picking up amyloid
in brains of some subjects even
pre-symptomatic subject but it's very
expensive in a sort of $5,000 plus PET
scan and of course the early you go in
its these process the less likely you
are to find someone with amyloid so
typically in clinical trial recruitment
you may have to carry out 10 scans to
find one positive individual the other
option here is a lumbar puncture where
we're taking out a sample of cerebral
spinal fluid to look for telltale
amyloid and tau protein fragments but
that's actually quite difficult to do
quantitatively and reproducibly
across many labs and of course it's
highly invasive having to take a lot of
punch a sample so we've been working on
the premise really set out by Professor
John Hardy at UCL from years ago that
genetic analysis would be the most cost
effective way of deciding who should be
assessed but we're using these more
invasive techniques for early signs of
disease developing on this slide you can
see actually that there are two forms of
Alzheimer's disease and our focus today
is on the late onset form by far the
most common form of Alzheimer's disease
a probably upwards of ninety five
percent maybe as much as ninety eight
percent is associated with late onset by
which we mean greater than 65 years of
age there is an earliest onset form of
course which occurred in families in
discrete families and these are
associated with dominant mutations in
the amyloid precursor protein the two
prisoners aging these are very well
documented late onset disease on the
other hand is associated with that
locus as we'll talk about shortly but
also with a large number of of loci
throughout the genome these 21 loads
right here were documented a few years
ago in a well-known publication but
since then they've been a large number
much larger number identified and these
are smugly have small effects and it's
the cumulative effect of these these
variants that seem to confer risk and
for the later onset form of the disease
so outline the disease of the late onset
variety is associated with many DNA
variants spread throughout the genome as
of this publication back in 2018 there
were over 40 different loci identified
each of which confer the variants confer
is a little bit of added risk or perhaps
a little bit of protection for the
development of the disease you can see
on the right-hand side here the advil we
locus is by far the most commonly
associated with increased risk but
depending on where you draw the cutoff
in this so-called Manhattan plot we can
identify large numbers of other risk
associated DNA variants so to summarize
what's needed on this slide we need we
can see that we need effective early
identification
ideally pre-symptomatic phase of at risk
individuals and the solution that we're
talking about today is a polygenic risk
or approach and our particular algorithm
we called Gina school which is driven
from a DNA sample either blood or a
mouth swab which is then isolated from
that sample today and then run on a
proprietary array we could vary a text
talk about that in a moment that variate
x-ray is built on a thermo Fisher axiom
platform run on the gene Titan equipment
and then the output from that array is
analyzed in our software platform a
proprietary platform called snip fitter
within which the Gina succour polygenic
risk score
algorithm sits so we get the primary
gene typing data from the array analyzed
using genus score in an automated
workflow run in whichever lab we're
working with apps to have this equipment
so we work regularly with akiza Jen in
the US with Europeans in Europe and
we've worked extensively with the RAM
ashati Center in Australia essentially
we can work with any lab that has this
laboratory infrastructure okay so the
Varia tech - array will be familiar to
some people we previously had two very
tick one array this is a new version
which contains something like five or
six times as many snips including all
the original very affect one content
plus optimized snip panels to drive the
polygenic risk score algorithms now that
the discussion today is really all about
the genus core algorithm but just for
information we do have other pologize
risk analyses that we can carry out from
the basic genotyping content of this
array and that analysis would be
available depending on exactly what the
experiment was trying to achieve but you
can see here you've got very panels of
snips some of which arose from our
collaborations at University College
London with John Hardy and his group
many of which come from Cardiff
University and optimized to drive the
algorithm on which genus score is based
talk about that shortly and some of the
man that come from mTOR associated
pathways which are from University of
Birmingham collaboration in the UK which
allows to drive other other formative
analysis we have an extensive literature
panel covering all the early-onset
associated variants in a PP piece n 1
and piece n 2 and of course we have
panels that would allow us to do
pharmacogenetics admin type studies as
well as imputation if that was required
so the Cardiff algorithm on which Gena
score is based is one of the best
published algorithms that's available
and if have some very key
characteristics it was trained a very
large database very large training set
so good I cap consortium data set and
contains a very large number of snips so
we're talking here about an algorithm
which in this publication the best
accuracy was achieved using more than
eighty seven and a half thousand snips
or DNA variants actually the genus Go
algorithm that I'm describing now has
got a bit more than knife but a few more
one hundred and fifteen thousand or so
and we find that this gives us the most
stable prediction across different data
sets relating to alzheimer's disease
risk in the samples that we've analyzed
and for which i'll show you some data
shortly a final point on this slide is
that the the validation of the carnot
algorithm has been done in completely
independent datasets some of which of
the following confirmed which is kind of
gold standard for outside the disease
definition and so we know that the
performance is not just due to the
overfitting in a training set that
indeed is preserved in completely
independent test sets which is a very
important characteristic and you can see
some dates are here from from exactly
those those sorts of test sets which
we'll cover in a bit more detail on the
subsequent slides so of course the
cardiff algorithm is not the only
polygenic risk or algorithm and i would
draw your attention to this paper that
was published last year by hannah
stocker
8ao which sets out to compare the
performance of different polygenic risk
score algorithms for predicting
alzheimer's disease
and essentially what hannah and her
colleagues concluded was the of the
algorithms available the cardiff
algorithm is the best performing the
highest performing in terms of accuracy
and it's one of only two that have been
actually tested and
firms pathology confirmed data set so
that that's very important when dealing
with a disease which can be quite
difficult to accurately clinically
diagnosed without post-mortem postmortem
if the pathology
correlation now one of the key
characteristics we're going to look for
in any apologetic risk or algorithm is
how it compares to a settling risk above
and beyond belief or you will recall
that I mentioned a couple of minutes ago
that appellee for is a risk associated
allele in fact it's the most
characterized of the risk so diety
alleles in for late onset Alzheimer's
disease but carrying efore itself or may
give you an elevated risk but does not
in any way determine whether or not an
individual will develop Alzheimer's
disease so it's important if you are
ready for carrier and this slide
illustrates the the distribution in a
general cognitively normal population
this in this case in the UK so about 23%
of the population carry one copy of e4
the so called III II for heterozygotes
and these would be considered to be a
relatively high risk but we know that a
lot of those people will not go on to
develop Alzheimer's disease conversely
the majority of people will not carry
you for but will fit into the III III
homozygote group and yet we know
something like forty to fifty percent of
our time in cases come from that III III
group so we can see automatically here
that efore assessment alone will not be
sufficient to have any clinical utility
in predicting the future likelihood of
developing Alzheimer's disease and
indeed that's the case now just before I
get on to shares and data at all point
here that we our job brilliance I talks
has been to take and build on the
academic excellence of the car did
research algorithm and turn it into a
validated product that can be then used
ultimately in the clinic so for that we
we've worked across a number of
different data sets
to be able in Australia investor
Pennsylvania Emory University and others
and we have to have to demonstrate with
bus'ness in all Apple we've genotypes
the algorithms I'm the algorithm I'm
focusing on today comes from Cardiff
University but there are others
available to that do slightly different
things for example the algorithm
university of birmingham that we
developed based on the mTOR pathway we
can talk about that on occasion people
can ask questions about match they wish
the array is customized array built on
the thermo Fisher axiom are a platform
for reasons of quality controls
essentially and we've got global access
by our partners pieces of Europeans and
other laboratories so if you think about
the data now why would we want to use
how would we expect to be able to use
this type of approach I think there are
several key reasons I mean one as I've
touched on already to identify the
clinical trial participants at the
earlier stages who are most likely to
competitive the cognitive decline during
the follow-up period of a therapeutic
trial so this will allow us of course to
reduce trial subjects and associated
costs and increase the chances
demonstrating their therapeutic effect
we've said already that we would need to
demonstrate a performance above and
beyond that associated with a buii
genotyping alone talk about that shortly
and of course what would be ideal we'll
be able to predict those at highest risk
of meaningful cognitive decline by which
I mean measurable objective ly
measurable cognitive decline within the
period of a clinical trial follow-up and
then another point in this slide the
last point actually is to do with
subtypes so the expectation is that some
drugs are more likely to be effective in
some subset of our planners disease
sufferers than others and this type of
analysis
lends itself to be able to effectively
identify those genetic subgroups and
therefore enrich in subsequent
therapeutic studies in a way
more to cancer drug development and the
use of prognostic markers the work I'm
going to describe now has all been
analyzed using these the so-called ad me
dataset Adney fantasy Alzheimer's
disease neuroimaging initiative
it's a long-running study that started
in 2004 one comes with very
comprehensive longitudinal follow-up
data and the subjects have been
confirmed using PET imaging so that
gives us a high level of confidence
based on the amyloid burden in these
subjects that the clinically defined
outside the cases really are Alzheimer's
disease rather than some other dementia
and the age-matched controls really are
controls and not simply pre-symptomatic
at risk amyloid alzheimer's subjects so
mostly work I'm going to be describing
now has been done in this cohort there
are over 630 Android confirmed subjects
and these are very well age-matched
across controls subject groups and mean
ages about 78 and what we can do in
these analyses is compare the
performance of our algorithm with other
other forms of ours and based on Apple
we alone or combinations of Apple we and
other other parameters as I'll describe
surely so if we look across the aadmi
data set and we ask how good are we have
this Gina score predicting clinical ad
from cognitively normal controls across
all our we eto types in other words this
is everyone thrown in together we can
see that if you do that using the after
we alone if an a you see an accuracy
measure essentially of about 73% the
polygenic risk score algorithm without a
weak component gives you about 70% in an
apple we independent measure if you
combine the two things together we come
up with an AUC of 80% so that's a
significant improvement above our weak
but of course this is in subject to
whom will be happily for carriers so if
we ask the question what happens if we
look at the e for high-risk subset
carriers within this group so these are
the heterozygote III e poor carriers are
we able to differentiate relatively high
and relatively low risk in this group we
can see that the by establishing
cut-offs using apologetic risk or
analysis in this case the top quartile
fell at the point 6 1 and above cutoff
we have positive predictive value of 84%
at the AUC level so that's that's that's
telling us we're able to pick out the
top quartile the highest rate of
subjects amongst that need for carrier
group and these are people you might
well want to enrich your your clinical
trial with and actually if you take that
that measure down that cutoff down to
give you the top 50% you're still at 71%
positive predictive value and this would
be hugely valuable to anyone wanting to
enrich a study cohort for those most
likely to develop the disease and
therefore once it should be recruited
into your clinical study if we take the
other end of the spectrum the Apple III
how the psychos who would be
conventionally thought of as having
relatively lower risk we can see here
that were able to stratify in this case
by taking the lower quartile with a
negative predictive value about 89 was
90% so we could definitely want to
eliminate those subjects from the
clinical trial on the other hand you
took the highest quartile you'd be up at
about 50% so positive predictive value
about 51% in this particular study so
you might want to include some of these
in your clinical trial so that your
indication would extend to those III III
homozygotes within the study parameters
been the inclusion exclusion criteria
for your study so so if we look at the
conclusions from the work I've just
described
studies that we are continuing to carry
out right now we can say that the
stratification of efore carrier
heterozygotes can identify the subset of
v4 carriers at the highest risk of
developing Alzheimer's disease of course
these are the ones you would want to
stratify and rich into your clinical
trial to measure therapeutic effect at
the other end of the spectrum the Apple
III homozygotes our now this is clearly
shown it's possible to identify a subset
of these individuals at the lower end of
the risk spectrum and would also allow
you to identify the higher risk III III
homozygotes to include in your in your
study design as well the the algorithm
has the potential to improve the ability
to fix individuals who will convert
their fault from mild cognitive
impairment to 80 well over and above a
per we alone and given the observations
that enrichment will be MCI and the
other prodromal at-risk subjects gives
you the highest opportunity to shape the
therapeutic effect this is very
important observation and we're doing
more work with this on this very
question at the moment using the Adney
cohort and using other cohorts as well
the algorithm clearly has the potential
to select those patient to a most likely
to decline cognitively within the time
frame of a clinical trial and that's
obviously crucial because without that
decline in a reasonable period of time a
therapeutic effects are very difficult
to measure the it's worth mentioning
that our genus score and indeed other
algorithms are available for research
collaboration at this stage and we're
working with a number of farmer biotech
and academic studies at the present time
and going forward we our intention is to
be to be engaging with the US and
European regulator authorities and look
for full marketing approval for clinical
version of our genus core algorithm in
the 2021 timeframe
I want to finish by acknowledging a team
and other partners very important
partners a very talented team here at
site ox in the UK and we work globally
with collaborators around the world key
partners for us as I've mentioned on
roof had been the dementia Research
Institute team at Cardiff University led
by Julie Williams and ballotine aresko
price and in particular two very
talented postdocs Effy bellow and Gunnar
en encode and of course John Hardy at
the UCL dementia Research Institute
Miriam show I again jobs postdoc there
we've of course relies heavily in this
presentation on the add new dataset
I'm very debted to add me and of course
Mike whiner the pi4 Abney and not least
all the patients volunteers and their
families who contribute very important
samples and of course their time to
commit to the expensive clinical
evaluations that are very important in
participating in those sort of studies
our funding at sight ox comes from a
number of sources not least our
investors but also from grant money
we've received continue to receive money
from innovate UK and we also receive
money from European Union so thanks very
much for your attention and I look
forward to answering your questions in
due course
and thank you dr. pepper
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question to be answered today is how has
your PRS been validated for example any
independent verifications
okay Susie thanks for that yeah so the
original training set as I mentioned
well the work was done by the Karthik
University team in the so called ICAP
training set a huge longitudinal well
almost ongoing study as and they
themselves did validation in completely
independent data sets including
pathology confirmed the so-called T Jen
dataset but than we've worked across
different different clinical data sets
from around the world the work that we
did was to take the Cardiff algorithm
and then and then test the performance
in the Abney dataset this longitudinal
15-year study that's still going on and
we we generated essentially very similar
data today to the Cardiff validation
work we've worked also in several other
longitudinal sample series and including
some from farmer studies but what we're
going to do now is take this truth to a
formal regulatory validation study in an
ongoing longitudinal sample set where we
we aim to go for FDA and EMA approval
for using this technique in a clinical
setting
so there are degrees of validation are
completed already and this certainly
supports the use in research use only
tap applications and there are more
formal regulatory studies which are
planned for the new year
thank you dr. pethor and do offer
testing as a service or do you provide
the platform only okay so what we've
done so far is redone more collaborative
type studies so and these could be of an
academic nature or they could be with
pharma companies we're approached on how
we should you know we like to understand
with the with our partners exactly the
question they're trying to answer then
we can work together to build an
appropriate study design so for example
we worked with the able team in
Australia I get again a very well known
longitudinal study we were able to
effectively send out our genotyping
arrays to their local laboratory
University of New South Wales collect
the genotyping data there and then do
all the the analytical work back in the
UK so we uploaded the genotyping data
into a cloud-based server did the
analysis here in the UK and then
provided the data back so we can work in
a very flexible way depending on exactly
what the collaborator is trying to
achieve
Thank You dr. pepper and I want to thank
our audience for participating today we
have some great questions coming in our
next question dr. pepper is can you
describe the key modules on the array
that were important for the PRS
algorithm sure yeah so that there are
fundamental pieces of information that
anyone interested in out some research
genetics will want to capture on an
array so for example will be dominantly
inherited mutations associated with
early onset Alzheimer's disease because
even if you're working with light late
onset cases you still want to know that
your your your you have a basically a
pure a pure data set and so we use that
in almost like a quality control
methodology but the primary aim of
course is to make sure you have good
coverage of all the snips with DNA
variants that are needed to drive the
algorithm itself so for that reason the
array is dominated by snips that drive
the Cardiff algorithm but also the snips
that drive the the more research or into
algorithm using the mTOR approach that
was developed by dr. Duchin our
University of Birmingham and that we
still working on in very much in
research mode so so the snip curation is
dominated by the function the functional
aspects of the algorithm itself but
there are other elements on there as
well so for example you know the the
aadmi snips snips associated with
wanting to to look for non Alzheimer
dementia associated associations as well
they are accidentally covered on the
array what we think we have with Varitek
too is the most comprehensive collection
of DNA variants and associated probes
for our climbers that there is available
today and of course we constantly
monitor literature and if new things are
discovered we can incorporate those onto
an expert next generation version to the
array as well
thank you and does this PRS algorithm or
another algorithm have any value in
predicting the rate of cognitive decline
that is a great question so and I'm sure
many people will know that the the rate
of cognitive decline is of huge interest
not just to patients and their families
but to farmer who want to know you know
how these things are determined and also
whether someone's likely to be on a
trajectory of decline that's measurable
within the period of a clinical trial
follow-up so I think the the answer is
the genetics plays a role in determining
that probably in some people but it's by
no means the only role so for example we
know that Alzheimer's disease often
comes as a part of a mixed pathology
with vascular dementia component as well
and it could be that that decline rate
is is dominated by non-genetic factors
in some people that said we are looking
at a progression data
so within Adney for example you've got
individuals who have changed over the
period of follow-up say from cognitively
normal to having a mild cognitive
impairment or indeed fill out signs
disease or conversely may have come into
the study with mild cognitive impairment
and then progressed to Alzheimer's we
are able to use or in our work that
we're doing at the moment does suggest
that it's possible to pick out those at
highest risk of decline within a
relatively short period of time
Thank You dr. pepper and here's our next
question from an audience member what
types of biological samples are required
for SNP genotyping okay so we have
validated our approach using either
blood samples or isolated DNA genomic
DNA or indeed mouth swab cheek swab
samples as well so so you know we've
used fresh blood we've used blood that's
been archived from clinical trials and
we've been with use DNA that's been
archived from clinical trials and the
nice thing about that in a DNA is a very
stable analyte so meaning you know we
will know you can dig up wooly mammoths
so you know there were frozen for
thousands of years and get sequence of
all DNA out of them so you know we can
use store DNA most of our work has been
done with biobank DNA that's come from
longitudinal farmer and or observational
studies such as Adney or Abel but going
forward and we have done quite a lot of
work already we know we expect to be
using quite a lot of cheek swab samples
and certainly the FDA discussions we'll
be having in a few weeks time will
include the use of both blood and mouth
swab as starting points for the DNA for
this type of analysis thank you and how
do you see PRS being utilized in pharma
well farmer have as I mentioned I mean
they've got a huge challenge which is to
get into subjects early enough to hit
that therapeutic window whereby there's
an active disease process but idea that
process hasn't progressed to the point
where that there's nothing left to to
salvage so we know that amyloid and tau
are building up you know perhaps 20
years or more before clinical symptoms
and that provides a fantastic window to
intervene in a meaningful time to
perhaps slow or you can prevent
cognitive decline the the challenge has
been how do you find those people we
explained that pet amyloid imaging and
how imaging is coming online to can be
used but they're very expensive very
invasive very time consuming techniques
and what you really want to do is
stratify those people up front of an
amyloid or indeed a tail PET scan before
you put them into a scanner and I think
this is where our technology can really
really have a lot of benefit and indeed
that's that's where we have shown
benefit in in being able to enrich
amyloid positive subjects so reduce the
the number of wasted PET scans if you
like and then of course farmer that are
looking beyond the clinical trial phase
to a time when new drugs are on the
market and of course you know the most
obvious example of this in recent weeks
was was by Jen's announcement that the
reanalysis of their phase 3 data from
engaged in emerge is looking quite
encouraging I mean the question is if
that was approved in the next year or so
how do you find patients early enough to
start treating them and you're not going
to be doing widespread PET scanning or
or a cerebral spinal fluid analysis
you're going to need to find a way to
identify the highest risk subjects
before they go into those tertiary sort
of screen so we think genetics and
apologetic risk or
that could play a really important role
in that setting as well
thank you dr. panther and thank you
again to our audience members for these
great questions our next question hello
and what do you consider an appropriate
time frame for a clinical trial during
which patients stratified as high-risk
group might progress from MCI to AD
that's the first part of the question
and then the second part is how would
such a trial have to be scheduled okay
so that's a great question and this is
completely aligned with the kind of
analysis that our technical team have
been carrying out in the Abney data set
over the last few months and and what we
can see actually is that if we look at
look at people with a clinical diagnosis
of MCI within adne and then we ask could
we predict progression in a two three or
four year time frame to a clinical
definition of Alzheimer's disease we're
able to do that with a an accuracy of
around about 70 plus percent its
pendings exactly on which criteria we're
using but 70 plus percent which is a
pretty good positive predictive value so
in other words these are people you
really want to enrich the high above a
certain cutoff for the project risk
score you don't to enrich these in your
clinical trial because these are the
people at highest risk of cognitive
decline and these are the people that
you be able to actually demonstrate
benefit in equally important we've been
looking at progression from cognitively
normal to MCI also in Abney and we can
also see a very good performance of our
Polident risk score in the highest
polygenic risk score subjects for
progression from MCI throw from
cognitively normal to MCI also within
within the Adney data set so depending
on which population you want to enrich
for we think that the apologetic risk
score approach is an effective way of
being able to do that
thank you and have you used dry dried
blood spots samples instead of fresh
blood I'm racking my brains and I'm
looking around some of my colleagues in
the room with me no I think the answer
is no we have not done that but I do
know that the axiom platform that we
built a very tech to rayon has been used
for exactly you know with exactly that
starting point so there's no reason why
we would not expect to be able to do
that as long as there was sufficient
blood or sufficient DNA in the blood
sample I don't think there's any reason
to why we wouldn't be able to to use
that as a starting point for a
genotyping and input for the polygenic
risk or analysis
thank you for that and how have you
accounted for sex differences in your
algorithm that's the first part of the
question and is it possible that females
and males may have different dementia
trajectories okay so I'm I'm going to
take the first part of that question
neon the answer that is we do or we we
have looked at age and gender as
covariates in the algorithm so we know
that there's a bully a lot of
publications suggest as a relatively
increased risk associated with females
versus males for developing Alzheimer's
disease and you can see that in some of
the cohort studies and you can apply a
factor in the algorithm a co-vary in the
algorithm to it to account for both
gender and age differences we have to
say we don't see in the studies we've
local Hempton a massive difference
between female and male but you know in
some studies for sure that that
observation has been made as for
different trajectories I mean I'm not
sure that we've got data ourselves that
would relate to that particular question
but certainly that something would be
interested in studying that was a of
academic interest and people had samples
from from those types of cohorts I think
it would be a very interesting research
question to try and address
you dr. panther our next question is
have you gained any biological insides
about ad mechanism by the proposed PRS
pipeline it looks like it is designed
mostly for early detection alone okay so
that's a great question we we have were
able to analyze the data according to
different biological pathways and that's
particularly true of our so called G
note or algorithm which I didn't talk
about today but which looks specifically
at pathways associated with the so
called mTOR pathway and the different
biological functions associated chemical
pathway so we haven't done a lot of work
ourselves our colleagues at Cardiff
University are very interested in this
particular question and I think it's
also got relevance possibly for
different ethnic groups as well so the
work that we've described today is is it
almost exclusively done in Caucasian
subjects and samples simply because of
availability and because that's where
most of the G where the genome-wide
Association data has been generated
which which basically is where we link
the the DNA variants to increase or
decrease risk of Alzheimer's disease but
there's a huge opportunity outside
Caucasian groups we know for example in
China because of the aging demographic
there's a massive problem with
Alzheimer's disease so having an
algorithm that was optimized for use in
that population for example would be a
huge clinical benefit we haven't done
that work here but it's something we'd
certainly like to to look at in the
future so yes and we have done some work
with our mTOR algorithm whereby we are
looking at groups of responders and
non-responders and then trying to relate
them back to different pathways
associated with mTOR biological pathways
effects and we can see some of that and
I'm certainly going forward we have a
have confidence that counselors
effectively will be definable in
discrete genetic subsets and I think
there was a paper that came out last
year I think perhaps earlier this year
that suggested that there were seven or
eight different sort of distinct genetic
subtypes of Alzheimer's disease that I
think that will be consistent with what
we see as well thank you dr. pepper and
we have time for a few more questions
our next one our audience asks have you
examined how the algorithm performs in
non-european ancestry populations yeah I
think I tried to cover that a little bit
in my previous answer we would love to
do this work but we just don't have the
resources at this time there are just
not many high-quality gys and high
quality and high number G wise datasets
available outside Caucasian populations
so all European ancestry populations so
that has been a limitation and it will
continue to be a limitation we know
there are various efforts going on
around the world at the moment I can
think of one example in Taiwan where
there's a big G wise study going on
there right now and in time as that data
becomes available it should unlock the
potential to to do this kind of work
outside those populations of European
ancestry and and we'd be very keen to be
involved in that if anyone was
interested in in that kind of
collaboration please do get in touch
with us after the call
thank you our next question do you
envision your array and software going
through a 510 K regulatory approval so
we envisage it going through a
regulatory approval and we are going to
be talking to the FDA
very soon through their pre submission
process whereby we can get feedback on
the most appropriate regulatory pathways
whether that's 510 K or whether that's
another designation I think remains to
be discussed and agreed with the FDA but
certainly we have ambitions to to gain
regulatory approvals in the US and
Europe and beyond ultimately for up for
both power or for our whole process
actually which includes the proprietary
array and this software algorithm the
genius core algorithm which is embedded
in what we call our snip fit a software
platform so yes absolutely that's our
ambition because as I've explained we
actually believe this technology has a
significant clinical role to play
ultimately
thank you and we have time for a couple
of more what are your plans for Gino's
score once you have achieved regulatory
approval well we'd like to roll it
around I roll ELQ you know it's a
clinical product around the world and
you know we we've got laboratory
partners that can help us do that
already lined up in the u.s. we work
with the keys again who are a specialist
genotyping laboratory in fact much more
than that just outside Atlanta in
Norwood and we've also got relationships
with Europeans as we mentioned earlier
so you know we need laboratory partners
and we also need marketing partners to
get this out to the widest audience but
but that all comes in time we need to
get the regulatory approvals in place
first we've got this network of
laboratories very high quality partner
laboratories set up for our research use
only collaborations and partnerships
with farmer and various academics and
that's a we've worked in various centers
in North America in Europe and in
Australia but there are there are more
of those to come and that will be all
part of our strategy to roll this out as
a full commercial product once we get
the approvals in place
Thank You dr. pisser we have time for
one more question our final question is
considering that the apoE genotype
distribution is based on the UK
population how can this be extended to
non Caucasian populations okay so let me
make sure I understand this question
correctly I think what we're saying here
is the distribution of April we've
bought every three carriers that I
quoted earlier was based on a UK
distribution that distribution is pretty
much mimicked in in populations of
European ancestry including many
populations within the US and and the
and so that sort of apoe4 three you know
about 20% of the population relatively
high risk would be considered but we
know that's the group we can stratify
further equally the ìiî ìiî homozygotes
that would because it's be of low risk
and we show that we can stratify those
as well so so we can do this in
populations of European ancestry of
Caucasian populations outside the
Caucasian populations there's work to be
done and we know it's very well
documented for example that the apoE
different April we genotypes have
different risk profiles in non European
African Americans for all Americans of
African origin African descent for
example so you know we know there's some
work to do here and I don't think the
genetics is fully understood yet but
there's there's a lot of work to do and
certainly we would like to validate our
algorithms in non-european and non
Caucasian populations
thank you dr. pepper and actually we
have time for a couple more questions so
we're going to push them through and let
you answer them because your research is
so wonderful
is there an associated threshold
requirement for a typical population
cohort size used for PRS and obtaining
significance and power of the results
and if there is at what range would it
be
that's a good question so I mean there
are obviously there are two constraints
here I mean what one is the well I mean
that constraint really limited by the
technology and by what you're trying to
show and I was to work trying to show
these a function of the difference in
the date in the dataset so we we have
done studies in a few hundred subjects
and being able to show significant
differences and male statistically
different so if that's the sort of I
mean that's the sort of range that we're
very happy working with but of course
ultimately what we'd like to do is be
able to tell you something about the the
risk or in an individual I mean that
that's really the challenge and so
that's that's got to that's all around
fixing the parameters of the algorithm
for a particular ethnic group such that
it can be used on an N equals one sample
so so there's a difference here I think
in what the source size of the
populations you would need to train an
algorithm and then validate it you know
which could be hundreds or thousands and
then how you would use it in the real
world where ultimately you're after an
answer and an individual
and dr. Vicktor is this currently
considered an LD t buy cap yeah so the
partner laboratory we work with in the
u.s. certainly is we will be working
with them on the basis of an LD TN cap
cap regulation certainly as an interim
but we again that's exactly the sort of
subject that will be matter we'll be
discussing with the FDA in in due course
but but yes I mean you can you could
certainly if you're interested in
operating to that that kind of level of
quality management then yes you can
obtain data from this platform in in a
CLIA approved of oratory Thank You dr.
Petra and how important is it for you to
work with a PRS that can achieve the
best AUC using the minimum SNP number
that's the first part of the question
and would you sacrifice a small AUC
percentage for saving on thousand of
snps yeah well I would refer this
questioner to one of Valentina Escott
prices papers actually where she did
exactly this where she looked at the
trade-off between AUC and the number of
snips that were incorporated into the
algorithm and there is a trade off but
but it's you know you know but you get
to a point where certainly you know the
performance doesn't increase very much
for the addition of a few more you know
few more hundreds in it I think what we
have seen though is in the algorithms
that use very low numbers you know I'm
talking about tens or even hundreds the
transition or the translation of
performance between one data set in the
neck seems to be very compromised so and
that's probably because you're
overfitting to a small number of snips
and and then therefore you know that
performance does doesn't translate
across data sets very effectively so I
would refer the question a question want
to get in touch with me please do and I
can then refer but refer them to this
paper that
Tina published on exactly this topic I
think it's also worth saying that the
Valentina published a paper a couple
years ago which suggested that the
performance of the algorithm that we're
seeing today is kind of at the
theoretical maximum that you would
expect the late onset Alzheimer's
disease given that it's not a pure
genetic disease you know we know from
identical twin studies that twins with
exactly the same genetic makeup may
develop the disease at different times
in their life and that's because their
exposure to environmental and lifestyle
risks are different so Jetix in
Alzheimer's disease never going to tell
you everything but we do think that the
the components captured in the polygenic
risk our algorithm that we've described
here with with genus score is at or
about that theoretical maximum
performance that you're ever going to
see with a polygenic risk approach thank
you dr. pepper and giving final comments
for our audience today no I I think I
mean I'd like to thank them for their
engagement I mean we've had a large
number of participants which is
fantastic and we've had some really good
questions which is even better so thank
you for that and I would very much
encourage you to get in touch with us I
my contact details are on the final
slide in the presentation so if anyone
would like to to reach out we'd be
delighted to to hear from you and to
perhaps even put some sort of
collaboration collaboration together so
thanks for your engagement everyone and
I'm I apologize if my my sore throat was
was too much of an irritation on the
call but hopefully you can understand
most of what I was saying
Thank You dr. pepper for your time today
and absolutely for your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go I
want to remind the audience that joined
us today thank you for your interesting
questions and any questions that weren't
answered today those submitted during
they will be answered and addressed by
dr. pisser
via email address that you provided at
the time of the registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon
buh-bye